can I just throw this out there because
it's one of my favorite movies of all
time
her rom-com Bride Wars remember that
opposite Kate Hudson well just turn 10
this month I love them together and I'm
ready for a reboot of that cab you love
a good wedding whether it's amazing or
whether it's real life let's be honest
thanks so much Kelty um you know
although kate does have her hands full
d-day these days raising three kids
including her newborn daughter Ronny
well now she's giving us a bit of
insight into her family dynamic here's
Kate's guide to modern parenting
you have a teenager and now you have a
baby
until and we're talking about all boys
and now here I am out this evening out
how is their sort of balancing out the
the masculine and the feminine it's
great the quote genderless approach
that's how kate is choosing to raise
three-month-old Ronny saying we still
don't know what she's going to identify
as I will say that right now she is
incredibly feminine in her energy it's
very different from the boys you know
Ronnie's there's just something kind of
magical about her the 39 year old mama
may have been influenced by her own
childhood as a tomboy quote my middle
brother Boston was basically my sister
because I put makeup on him all the time
and I dress him up and he loved it but
what does Kate say about getting married
again she recently reposted this
swimsuit that debuted at the Chanel
Fashion Show she captioned her guy Danny
Fujikawa hurry up and propose my wedding
looked just walked down the runway Danny
is the greatest he's also just an
incredibly supportive partner for me I
feel like I hit the jackpot I think that
sounds like she might get married again
she's ready and by the way she does it
all she is a mogul a mama and she's of
course an actress she sure does ever UK
[Music]
[Applause]